well I had a great time speaking at
embry-riddle university here in Daytona
last night
it's an air it's an Aeronautics
University so a number of the students
are going to be commercial airline
pilots so afterwards at dinner I was
interrogating them about the the
specifics of flying you know trying to
allay my fears of flying and it turns
out by the way in case you were worried
about this also it turns out that it's
probably not likely that a plane will
accidentally go too high and end up in
outer space so that if you were it's
good to hear and I'm sure you were
worried about it as well and so you
don't have to worry about that so
overall it was it was a it was a good
good experience now there's a lot to get
to today but first I have to tell you
about this because right now there are
50 million kids attending America's
public schools and the left really isn't
even trying to hide their agenda anymore
they've made it clear that their
intention is to indoctrinate the next
generation into their ideology and
that's what that's what's happening in
our in many of our public schools and
while that happens real-world skills
like reading and writing and arithmetic
in American history have been replaced
with things like social justice and
gender confusion
not to mention this whole process of you
know just memorization and regurgitation
is sort of the the method that's used in
these schools thankfully though you do
not have to consign yourself to that you
do have a choice and that is why Freedom
Project Academy was created that's
Freedom Project Academy it's an
accredited classical online school built
on judeo-christian values for students
in kindergarten through high school
Freedom Project Academy has taken the
interaction of the traditional classroom
but then it's created this online
atmosphere where students can learn from
from live instructors live teachers in
small classes who teach kids how to
think kind of think critically which is
a skill that's lost these days not just
what to think it's not just about
parroting information it's about
learning how to think through problems
so go to freedom for school comm and
request your free information packet
today that's freedom for school calm and
don't forget to subscribe
their weekly podcast the dr. Duke show
available in iTunes and more take back
control of your kids education freedom
for school comm freedom for school comm
freedom for school calm
okay well the Washington Post has
humiliated itself yet again this time
coming after Ben for tweeting that the
notre-dame Cathedral is a monument to
Western civilization Shapiro cleverly
said on his Twitter while the while the
fire was going on he said that it's a
monument to Western civilization the
cathedral is and to judeo-christian
heritage I think was the phrase now this
according to Thalia laven at the the
post is a racist dog whistle and it's a
llama phobic and it's incitement and
it's you know potentially encouraging
violence so she wrote a whole article
about all the so-called
far-right people stoking violence over
the over the cathedral burning and you
know this is this it's all it's all
white you know because when you say when
you say judeo-christian values that's a
cent you're essentially a neo-nazi right
because that's that's what Nazis would
do they they really cared about
judeo-christian values didn't they now
meanwhile I I haven't really seen anyone
stoke violence over the cathedral
burning certainly not been I have but I
haven't really seen anyone do it but
this this criticism has been repeated by
a lot of people on the Left and in the
media it seems that somehow against all
odds we on the right have become the
real villains here with the cathedral
you know being on fire now it doesn't
appear that there are any actual
villains in this case it seems like it
was just an accident that's where all
the evidence that's where all the
evidence points but I don't know how how
did this turn into a thing about the
about the far right
like what did we do we were just sad
about it that's all are we allowed to be
sad about about about this this building
being partially destroyed now let's just
go through a few points here first of
all of course Ben
right the cathedral is a monument to and
of and by Western civilization it's also
of course a monument to God a monument
to the Catholic faith but these are not
mutually exclusive categories okay it's
it's all of those things all at once the
cathedral is a monument to Western
civilization in the same way that you
might say that in a slightly different
way the world trade centers in New York
were a monument to America and a lot of
people around 9/11 said that sort of
thing and it was true now it's not the
only thing that the World Trade Center
was but in a sense it was also that
that's the significance of it that's the
significance that the World Trade Center
had to the United States and this is a
significance that the notre-dame
Cathedral had to Western civilization
and that's why I think by the way the
parallels that are drawn between you
know the cathedral and 9/11 make some
kind of sense now certainly 9/11 and
what happened this week completely
different things especially with the
human cost you know 3,000 people died on
9/11 fortunately nobody was killed with
the cathedral thank God but just in the
symbolism and the experience of seeing
those buildings destroyed in terms of
the buildings that's where you find that
parallel so there's nothing wrong with
pointing that out
and there's nothing wrong with talking
about Western civilization you know
we're told now that to to discuss
Western civilization to extol Western
civilization to express any gratitude or
feelings of warmth for Western
civilization and what it means that is
all racist now like you're not allowed
to do that and that's obviously
completely absurd and it should go
without saying that all the people who
are who are you know who feel that we're
not allowed to talk about the virtues
and the glory of Western civilization
all the people who make that claim
they're all in the West right these are
people who are also in Western
civilization
living off the fat of the land enjoying
the fruits of being in Western
civilization and it's only because they
are so spoiled and because they are you
know living such a comfortable life
thanks to the civilization they happen
to be born into it's only because of
that that they can afford to sit back
and be critical about things like this
and that's of course the great irony to
it second point is the other thing that
I guess upset folks on the left and got
us accused of being Islamophobic is that
when the when the the fire was happening
there were some people who thought that
it seems suspicious and we're wondering
if maybe this was intentional okay and
that it's not Islamic it's racist or
stoking violence or conspiracy theories
it was a perfectly valid thing to think
and question to ask now again it appears
according to all available evidence that
it was just an accident
but at the time you know this it's it's
it's the month first Monday of first day
of holy week right after Palm Sunday you
know said nine this is a nine hundred
year old building one of the most
significant buildings in all of
Christendom that's now on fire burning
there have been other attacks on on
churches and France and the past so it's
just of course people are gonna wonder
that there's nothing wrong with
wondering that and this idea that you're
not even out you're not even allowed to
think that it's just it's just of course
absurd
especially because every single person
who turned on the news and saw the
coverage everyone must have for at least
a moment thought the same thing like
what's going on here and that's
perfectly okay okay quick a quick update
here on Jesse Smollett and then I'm
gonna get two emails a lot earlier than
I usually do because there are a bunch
of interesting ones it's gonna be some
some some fascinating conversations I
want to leave time for it but first
this according to Fox News reading from
article on Fox News it says Cook County
State Attorney's kim fox state's
attorney kim fox described empire actor
jussie Smollett as a quote washed-up
celeb to the cops in text messages
released Tuesday by her office in
response to a public records request by
the Chicago Tribune Fox compared summa
let's case to her offices pending
indictments against our Kelly she said
in text messages to Joseph maggots
maggots I'm gonna figure out how to
pronounce that guy's name eventually her
top assistant she said quote pedophile
with four victims ten counts washed-up
celebrity count two cops 16 counts just
because we can charge something doesn't
mean we should and then she continued on
a case eligible for deferred prosecution
I think it's indicative of something we
should be looking at generally okay so
we have her now they're there and
they're a bunch of other text messages
I'm not going to go through all of them
but you should go and check out the
reports on these text messages because
it raises a few questions one of those
questions is well I thought she recused
herself from the case but she seemed to
still be involved and expressing her
opinions about the way things should be
handled right so raises that question
but also of course right there she's
acknowledging that she knows that he
lied yet he was still let off the hook
so any notion that was in anyone if
there's any notion left in anyone's head
that justice Millette was let go because
he's an innocent or because they you
know they uncovered some some evidence
that seemed to vindicate him now it was
clear all along that that's not the case
but you could look at these text
messages this is the woman who made who
made that call even though she recused
herself and should have been making any
calls at all but she acknowledges right
there that he lied to cops so that's all
and his his career should be destroyed
based on that he should not be working
in Hollywood ever again I don't know if
that's gonna that's actually how it's
going to work out but it's it's it's
I mean everyone involved in the
situation that looked at it including
the people who decided to let him off
the hook
even they everyone acknowledges he's
guilty everyone knows it and they let
him go anyway so it seems like there's
some real corruption going on there all
right yeah I'm gonna I want to go to my
email inbox right now because like I
said there a bunch of interesting ones
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com so let's see here this
is from from Riley says you mentioned on
your show yesterday how people were
criticizing Ilhan Omar for her tweet
about the burning down of Notre Dame I
agreed with you that you that it was not
something worth attacking her over I
think she's a vile woman but I didn't
see a problem with that particular tweet
why I have conservative critics come
down so hard on her over this despite
the fact that many the many many other
reasons to criticize her I found this I
find this counterproductive and damaging
to the conservative message well I agree
with you Riley that's why I made that
point yesterday I think for whatever
reason these days it's just that there's
very little discernment right so we're
constantly engaging in this overly
simplistic thinking all the time so the
calculation is that Omar is bad there
for everything she says is bad there for
everything she says deserves criticism
and so therefore whatever she happens to
say we have to look at it and find a
reason to criticize but the discerning
mind will say okay I disagree with so
much of what this woman says so much of
it is deserving of criticism but not all
of it in fact as a human being she is
capable of saying reasonable things and
even good things and on those occasions
I should not criticize at a minimum and
perhaps indeed maybe I should even give
her credit on those occasions but that
little slight nuance in thinking is I is
apparently too difficult for a lot of us
to muster and that's what I've noticed a
big problem now that so many people
struggle to to have any kind of nuanced
thoughts it just they're not capable of
any nuances in thinking whatsoever
everything has to just everything has to
be as simplistic and black and white as
possible
and that's that's that's the thought
process here and I think it's pretty
damaging
from david says on a recent podcast you
mentioned that joel osteen has a globe
as the center focus of his stage are you
just jealous that his globe is bigger
than your globes not jealous of that I'm
not jealous this is from Jake's as
dictator overlord Matt Walsh big fan of
your show never really been into
political podcast but you always bring a
strong and convincing a typically
entertaining argument for Christian
values in the political sphere plus I
figured if you're going to be a
merciless fascist dictator of the
universe in the near future I might as
well get to know where you stand on a
lot of these issues that's good thinking
I have a million questions I'd love to
ask but I'll stick to a single question
for the sake of brevity I'm a born and
raised Lutheran from Michigan and we
don't really talk about spiritual gifts
much when I say spiritual gifts I'm
referring specifically to supernatural
powers that some churches believe God
grants Christians to help them either
worshiping him or ministering to others
the most interesting one to me is
speaking in tongues and also the
interpretation of tongues a supernatural
language that we can't understand but
God can if you had asked me a couple of
years ago I would have said that gifts
like speaking in tongues and prophecy
don't exist anymore and that speaking in
tongues probably never existed
however after memorizing one first
Corinthians last year I said 1
Corinthians and I take my biblical cues
from Donald Trump on that after
memorizing first Corinthians last year
and becoming involved with some friends
in a non-denominational Church I've
started to question my existing belief
1st corinthians 12 through 14
particularly 14 seems to suggest that
speaking in tongues was a real thing at
paul's time and may still have a place
in the church today if that were true
that would suggest that nearly all
Lutheran Catholic etc churches are
neglecting this Nick this gift and their
congregation by not making room for it
in their services I'm still skeptical
but I'm trying to understand what's
going on when friends of mine tell me
they speak in tongues occasionally a
church they say they're driven by the
spirit and can't control it when it
happens but they consider it a wonderful
worship
your humble servant Jake okay well Jake
I thank you for addressing me correctly
and because you did that I promise that
when I am dictator I will execute you
last so you have my pledge on that
unless I changed my mind which I
couldn't as for speaking in tongues yes
we are clearly told that this was a gift
enjoyed by the Apostles and some early
disciples though at Pentecost there's a
discussion to be had about whether the
miracle was in the disciples speaking
foreign languages or in the hearers
hearing their own language despite
whatever the disciples happen to be
saying I think the Church Fathers were
split on that about like what was was
the miracle in the speaking or in the
hearing but in any case speaking in
tongues however however it worked okay
it did happen back then and it served a
very clear purpose and I certainly would
never rule out the possibility of
someone in the intervening years or in
modern times having the same gift so I'm
not saying that it's impossible right
Who am I to say that God can't or won't
perform a certain miracle however
speaking in gibberish is not speaking in
tongues and I'm not aware of any modern
cases of someone at a Pentecostal Church
suddenly speaking in like Punjabi or
something like that you know or even
French or you know any any language now
if that happens that's a miracle for
sure if someone who's who's never heard
or certainly never taking the time to
learn a foreign language suddenly starts
speaking it fluently then okay you've
got a miracle on your hands and that is
that is speaking in tongues but
gibberish is just gibberish and that's
almost always what's going on when
modern people speak in tongues now I'm
told anecdotal stories of people
breaking into real foreign languages or
or speaking in Jimmer gibberish that
some foreign or present hears as their
own language now if those anecdotes are
true than great
the vast vast vast majority of these
cases these days are just nonsense
in fact linguistic experts have studied
the gibberish of those who are speaking
in tongues in modern churches and they
found that it's it's not any kind of
language whatsoever it's not even that
it's it's not a known human language but
that it doesn't it doesn't follow the
structure of any language it's it's just
not in language it's the same few sounds
repeated over and over again okay it
really is it's just like a toddler
babbling it's it's nothing the point
being that a lingua a linguistic expert
could hear a language that they've never
encountered before and they might not
understand it but they could recognize
it as a language because they know how
languages are structured but glossolalia
in the modern church which speaking in
tongues that's the technical technical
term for it in most cases it seems it's
it's nonsense it's simply nonsense what
would be the point of it anyway why
would God miraculously give people the
power to speak nonsense that nobody
around them can understand it seems that
there's no function other than the
aggrandizement of the person doing it
in fact these tongue speakers are having
the exact opposite effect
of those who spoke in tongues in the
early church back then people who
witnessed it were amazed and stunned and
were converted right but these days
anyone who is not inside that particular
clique of Christianity we're speaking in
tongues is a regular thing everyone else
outside of it they look at it in
embarrassment and unbelievers walk away
with a worse impression of Christianity
than they had before so it's it does the
has the exact opposite effect before it
was about evangelizing to non-believers
on people who you know speak other
languages now it just makes everyone
laugh and walk away so again what's the
point why would God miraculously instill
in people the ability to babble
nonsensically is that a miracle I could
do it I'm not going to I could do it
right now so it's not a miracle if I
could just do if anyone can do it at any
point of their own free will and power
then it's not a miracle and there's no
reason to think that it's a gift of the
Holy Spirit
though again I'm not claiming that
speaking in tongues couldn't happen
today or dozen I'm just addressing the
vast majority of such alleged cases
where it's it's it's simply simply
nonsensical and you know these these
gifts of the Holy Spirit these racks
especially yeah these kind of really
what would if it was if they're real
it's a really dramatic miraculous gift
of speaking in tongues now this is not
it's not a smorgasbord buffet
we're just anyone is supposed to be able
to do it like speaking in tongues if you
read in the gospel and in Acts it was a
particular that was given to a certain
small number of people for us a reason
that was not just for you to be
impressed by them or for them or for
those people themselves to feel wholly
or to feel in touch with God it was not
the point it was a specificall my gosh
specifical that's what I just said
see now I'm speaking in tongues I am now
speaking in tongues I have been reduced
to gibberish it was a miracle hallelujah
so look it's a specificall thing all
right speaking in tongues is a specific
gift that was given could still be given
but now we treat it as just this thing
open to everybody anyone can do it and
as if the Holy Spirit is like Oprah
right you speak in tongues and you can
speak in tongues and you can speak in
tongues and meanwhile no one can
understand what anyone is saying so no I
don't I mean look it's the same thing
with you know people well you got the
entire churches of people falling over
and you know overcome by the Holy Spirit
and it's it's it's some of I'm not
saying that all these people are faking
I think some of them are faking I think
there's also a kind of peer pressure
where if you're in a church like that
and everyone
doing it and you feel like you have to
do it too which is another indication
this is not from the Holy Spirit okay
because the Holy Spirit is not gonna put
you in a situation where you feel peer
pressured to pretend that you have
miraculous gifts right so you know I
think there's peer pressure I think
there's I think there's I think there is
some faking but I also think there's
there's the power of persuasion right
think about I'm just gonna just my mark
from here I'm just I'm a mess today guys
really think about hypnotists okay now
do we believe that hypnotists have
magical powers yet a hypnotist can get
people to do all kinds of crazy things
is it because they have magical powers
no it's just the power of persuasion
you're you're convincing someone that
you have the power to make them so I'm
gonna ring this bell and you're gonna
bark like a dog
okay that's not you if you are not
susceptible and willing to be persuaded
no one can hypnotize you now it's not
like with a hypnotist they it's like
something from the cartoons where they
wave a watch in front of your face and
then your eyes turning the little
spirals and you turn into a zombie that
will do whatever they say no if you go
into a hypnotist and you're skeptical
and you're like this is stupid then it's
not gonna work because you are not open
to persuasion but if you're open to
being persuaded and being influenced and
you're caught up in the moment then
you're gonna feel like you were really
hypnotized and so that's I think what is
going on most of the time it's
essentially essentially like hypnosis
which again is not of the Holy Spirit
this is from Ken says hey Matt it became
clear to me in your response to the
woman's email about the rapture doctrine
that you are not going to buy into it no
matter how much scriptural basis there
might be for it and this seems to be
because if it wasn't known of the first
century or soon thereafter it could
never be known I would point out to you
that it was the Catholic Church that
held the geocentric theory of the cosmos
as sacred truth for over 1,200 years
based on their quote infallible unquote
interpretation of the same scriptures
that you and I have and even put people
to death who questioned it then
Copernicus Kepler Newton
Leo came along to show this doctrine to
be an error oh shoot how can that be it
was believed for 1,200 years it must
have been right oh I know our
astronomers are lying to us and the Sun
really does orbit the earth as I recall
the whole Reformation was based on the
assumption that serious issues regarding
the nature of salvation had arisen over
the previous twelve hundred years that
needed to be put to light but hey what
do I know about all this but then you
said that Paul's description of the Son
of Man in first Thessalonians was
metaphorical you asked why would Jesus
need such theatrics is how you put it I
wonder how much else of the Bible you
consider metaphorical if this is
metaphorical how much else is in
scriptures metaphorical maybe Jesus
really didn't mean that hell was real
for example maybe he meant that hell was
just a metaphor for suffering in this
life as a result of the Unforgiven sin
maybe heaven itself as a metaphor since
we can't point to it as you so aptly
point out but just so we were clear
about where Paul got this metaphorical
picture of Jesus being theatrical here's
the Lord Jesus Christ Himself describing
his return in Matthew 24 so if anyone
tells you there he is out in the
wilderness do not go out or here he is
in the inner rooms do not believe it for
as lightning that comes from the east is
visible even in the West so will be the
coming of the Son of Man wherever there
is a carcass there the vultures will
gather immediately after the distress of
those days the Sun will be dark into the
moon will not give its light the Stars
will fall from the sky and the heavenly
bodies will be shaken then will appear
the sign of the son of man in heaven and
then all the peoples of the earth will
mourn when they see the Son of man
coming on the clouds of heaven with
power and glory now that you have
mentioned it it sounds really theatrical
to me to notice that Jesus says
specifically that people will see him as
he comes on the clouds must be imaginary
clouds by the way first thessalonians is
an exact representation of what Jesus
has said here I never thought of this
maybe Paul was thinking that Jesus was
just being extra hyperbolic probably to
scare people into thinking into keeping
watch as that woman's email said though
for what event who can really say
certainly not for the rapture when God's
elect will be gathered etc etc one more
question if first Thessalonians in the
following is metaphorical what is the
metaphor for
okay Ken first of all I do appreciate
the sarcasm that's a one of them the
sarcasm dripping all over that email and
it's someone who speaks sarcasm I do
appreciate that so I thank you for
speaking in my tongue with with that and
I maybe you were spurred on by the Holy
Spirit Ken sarcasm be a gift of the Holy
Spirit I mean I don't know as for the
the geocentric theory you're right that
most Christians were mistaken on that
point not just Catholics but most people
across the world and throughout history
were mistaken on that point for a very
long time and you know understandably so
science had not progressed yet to the
point where you know most people would
be convinced that the Earth revolves
around the Sun but what changed
everyone's mind and the church's mind
was the science right in other words it
wasn't that someone had made an
innovative new theological discovery in
the text of the Bible but that someone
had made an absolutely undeniable
scientific discovery so the Earth
revolves around the Sun it just does
that's the reality there's no way around
it pun intended and so and so Christians
had no choice but to go back and
reassess those verses which which seemed
to them to indicate geocentrism but now
that they could see that
well geocentrism is wrong clearly we get
it just it just is so you have to go
back look at those verses again you must
have been wrong about them that's how
that worked that in my mind is totally
different from someone 18 or 19th
centuries later discovering some
heretofore unknown doctrine in the text
of the Bible itself and not based on any
external discovery or anything like that
but just based on their own subjective
reading of the scripture which is what
happened with the modern idea of the
rapture and and in what I'm disagreeing
with is that modern idea that the good
people are beamed up to heaven everyone
else is stuck on earth for a bit etc
that whole scene which has become so
elaborate and specific but which nobody
for 18 or 19th centuries of Christianity
knew anything about and which was
supposedly discovered in the text after
nearly 2,000 years and yes I have an
issue with that I do I I mean
is it is it possible that someone 18 or
19th centuries later could just discover
something through their playing the
plain reading of the text that no one
else noticed I'm not saying it's
impossible but it's it's something I'm
going to be highly skeptical of yeah
now I already said that though I'm not I
said I'm not sitting here and saying
that the end of the world will not
involve some people being up in the sky
or whatever else maybe it will I don't
know my whole point is I'm not getting
into elaborate and super specific
predictions about what exactly the end
of the world will look like I'm not
doing that
or when it will come or any of that
based on highly metaphorical text in the
Bible I think it's bad practice to do
that Christians have been doing that for
a long time and they keep getting it
wrong over and over and over again oh
the end is coming now the end is coming
now the end that's coming now oh we're
in so last day that's coming it's any
minute now over and over again for two
thousand years Christians have been
saying that at what point do we stop and
just admit look I have no idea when the
world's gonna end I have no idea what
its gonna look like and and that's it
and why does it matter why do you even
need to know why I get attached to this
specific vision of what the end of the
world is gonna look like you're probably
gonna be dead before it happens anyway
and so will I and I say probably because
every Christian in history up until now
has died up until our generation has
died before the end so I mean odds are
we're going to be the same there's no
reason to assume otherwise there were
many Christians in history who had many
who had much better reason to assume the
end was coming for that from for them
than we do as I said the Black Plague
wiped out you know whatever whatever the
percentage was of of Europeans I figured
with a huge percentage of of Europe was
wiped off the map at a few years because
of the Black Plague now and and people
back then thought well this has got to
be the end of the world everyone like
everyone's dying and this has to be the
end and but it wasn't was it and we
don't have anything like the Black
Plague we've got our challenges we've
got nothing like that
so I I just don't get it I mean and and
when you read when you read Daniel when
you read revelation you yes those texts
are heavily metaphorical of course they
are no one knows exactly what they're
saying or what they mean or what they're
what picture they're really painting in
a literal sense nobody knows that that's
why people have been debating these
texts for 2,000 years and anyway and
anyone who says oh I've got the oh I got
it no no I know yeah I finally figured
it out guys anytime someone does that I
I yes I would be very skeptical of that
I would be what makes you so special
yeah how about that should be your
question to that person okay so for
2,000 years no one knew exactly what
revelation was saying you figured it out
what makes you so special so you're the
one huh you you so you've got the
special line with God that nobody else
had maybe you do but it's I'm gonna be
skeptical of that claim
now you mentioned the the son of man
coming on the clouds of heaven
ah is that a medical statement yes
obviously you would agree that there's
some elephant element of metaphor or
poetry in that image right I mean heaven
doesn't literally have clouds heaven is
not literally in the clouds right Ken I
mean you would agree it's not when you
look up in the sky you see the clouds
heaven isn't literally there it's not
there not sitting actually on the clouds
so clouds of heaven obviously is
metaphorical language heaven doesn't
have clouds that in in the sense that we
know of them and and that's that's it's
that's that is yes that's metaphorical
language which is fine why is it
metaphorical language well because we
just don't have the words or the
concepts for what heaven is or what it
looks like for someone to cross from
that dimension into ours so we use words
like a descend and ascend and clouds and
yes even the word heaven is metaphorical
now the word heaven is metaphorical
which isn't to say that heaven doesn't
exist I'm saying the concept
that the word heaven grasps grasps for
is beyond our grasp and so we are left
with these kinds of words and ideas to
approximate it now the word heaven when
you say heaven heavens that denotes you
follow the etymology of that language
that demote the notes literally the sky
so yes that is a metaphorical word we
say that heaven is up there right the
big man upstairs
well he's not upstairs it's not really
up there it's not a physical location
situated above us therefore you don't
literally have to ascend physically to
it but you do ascend spiritually but
again these are just all of these
concepts are beyond our understanding so
we are left with this kind of language
we hear that Christ ascended into heaven
well as I said I believe that he did
literally go up in the sky but that was
for the benefit of those watching
because they wouldn't have understood
what they were watching if Christ had
traversed from this dimension to the
other in any other way you know it had
to be done in a physical way so that
people could wrap their heads around it
and describe it later and talk about it
and we could kind of understand what was
happening so the whole idea of a rapture
people going into the sky well where are
they going do you think heaven do you do
you think heaven is actually up near the
moon somewhere so they have to literally
fly in the sky to get to it why would
people need to fly into the sky to get
that there was a point in Christ's
ascension the physical representation of
a spiritual reality that we can't grasp
so I get that but this modern idea of
the rapture it seems like people flying
into the sky would be just what to show
off to the poor saps who are left behind
so who knows maybe that is what it will
look like I don't know but there are
some issues there that's all and just
one other point here that I don't know
why people get so afraid of this word
metaphor or metaphorical it's not yes
there's a lot of metaphorical language
in the Bible that doesn't it doesn't
mean that it's not true it doesn't mean
that it's a lie it doesn't mean that
it's fake it doesn't sound what
metaphorical means it just means that
there's maybe maybe when you
often when you hear the word
metaphorical you could probably usually
substitute poetic or something instead a
word like that it's just it's using
simply language that we can get our
heads around to describe something a
reality that we can't really get our
heads around and so we're left we have
to use some kind of language to describe
it and so this is the language that we
use so I you know I don't get it I don't
I don't understand why people recoil at
the notion of metaphor in the Bible yes
there's of course there's a lot of
metaphor are you gonna deny that
revelation is metaphor there's a lot of
metaphor I mean or do you think that
there's literally gonna be chariots and
stuff and actually actual real horses
coming out of the sky and things like
that I mean a maybe then that's what
will happen but I don't think that's
what the book of Revelation is trying to
tell us that we should be looking out
for real horses right I think it's a
metaphor for something so all right from
Stu and Hawaii says hi madam just
listening to your show today when you
talk about the devastating fire and
Notre Dame what the church and its
beauty represents and beauty as a
fundamental human need I could not agree
more I grew up in South America
specifically in Venezuela but I've lived
in the United States for over half my
life I grew up Catholic and always
remember as kids going to church on
Sunday with my grandmother and feeling
peaceful and surrounded by beauty and
faith inside my community small church
when I moved to the US as a young adult
I was unimpressed by the ugliness of
some churches that look like a fancier
version of a warehouse or a shopping
mall it seems so obvious that some
churches were more like a business
instead of a place of worship at one
point I went to a Christian Church for a
while because it was close to home
out of curiosity but the whole scene to
me was to over-the-top with a band
playing on stage non-stop a pastor with
headsets people dancing euphoric on
stage it looked like a show to me and
simply couldn't I simply couldn't handle
it nowadays when I go to church
occasionally I go to a small Catholic
Church nearby that reminds me of my
childhood Church it's simple but
tastefully decorated peaceful and where
I can focus on myself God and what I'm
there for instead of feeling like I'm
watching a performance I wish all
churches made more effort in building /
creating
architecture that inspire us and help us
all reflect in God's beauty and the
wonders that surround us thank you for
all you do and keep up the good work so
that's interesting stew because you seem
to be if I followed you here you're
saying that so you're not really a
regular churchgoer but even as someone
who doesn't go to church regularly when
we when you do go to church what you're
looking for is a church you're looking
for a churchy
Church experience right but for lack of
a better term and you know I hear that a
lot actually from from people that and
this I think is one of the problems with
the secularization of modern worship
with the you know the the the ugliness
of the church buildings and just the way
everything what you're talking about
where it turns into it's just the modern
church experience is supposed to look
like some sort of Broadway show or
something the problem is that you know
if somebody wants that they don't have
to go to church for it
like if you want that you can go to a
motivational seminar at your local hotel
conference room or you could go to an
actual rock concert I mean there if
that's all you want if you're looking
for that kind of just experience of
watching a show or simply being
motivated in an earthly sense or even
just having fellowship with people
around you I mean there are so many
other ways you can get that that all the
sudden the church serves no purpose you
so when you when you turn your church
service into that you it serves no
purpose anymore is that you might as
well just close up shop because what are
you even doing
you're not giving anyone anything that
they can't get plenty of other places
and you know something they could get a
better version of it somewhere else like
if you want to turn your church service
into a rock concert here's the thing
it's not gonna be a better rock concert
than what I could find if I went to a
real rock concert you know I've been the
plenty of real rock concerts and with
with super talented musicians who know
how to put on a show and so if I want
that I
go to that and as I said if I want a
motivational seminar type of thing I can
go to someone who can give me that I can
I can read a self-help book if I want if
I just want to fellowship and with my
fellow man then I can go to the pub with
some friends and have a beer I mean
which and these are all fine things to
do but the church has to offer something
different something that you can't get
those other places and so when you go
into an actual church it looks like a
church and feels like a church and
everything is very Orthodox and
religious and focused on religion
and there's religious you know art and
imagery and everything so it's a whole
it's and then it's you've created a
whole experience that is totally
different from an experience that
someone can get somewhere else so at a
minimum you've given people a reason to
come because they've you you are
offering them something different so you
don't look here's what you don't want
you don't want to be like the Burger
King that sets up shop right next to the
McDonald's right because you know I'm
only going to Burger King if if I'm
driving through town and I'm on the road
and there are no other options and I'm
like okay I guess I got to go to Burger
King crap but if I'm looking for
fast-food and there's a McDonald's right
there I'll just go to McDonald's because
when it comes to fast food at the end of
the day McDonald's they do it the best
they they they you know went just across
the board they've got it down they know
what they're doing so if you're going to
set up a restaurant next to McDonald's
set up a completely different kind of
restaurant so that you would give
someone a reason they might say okay you
know what I don't actually want fast
food at all here's a different thing
I'll go there I'll check that out I
think a lot of churches have just turned
into Burger Kings basically they've
turned into a to Burger Kings to the
world's McDonald's and and that's why
they're dying
all right finally this is from us is
from Matt says hi Matt nice name by the
way I have a lot of free time so I keep
I find myself delving into conspiracy
theories online quite often so biggest
interests aliens Mandela effect I don't
even what the Mandela effect is and
shared trips with hallucinogens so
naturally I have a theological question
for you if we were hypothetically
contacted by sentient extraterrestrials
how does that impact Christian doctrine
past past here you don't have to read on
the show okay well I'm gonna read it on
the show if you don't mind my thoughts
on this take a basic logical approach
since I believe the ability to reason is
next is the next greatest gift received
by Adam second only to freewill so my
lap my logic goes that God definitely
wouldn't create sentient life on two
different planets leaving one blind to
the gospel without means of salvation as
it would be obviously cruel so from that
one supposition I reason that there are
either one no aliens out there or two
aliens that are identical to humans the
religion of which functions only for
them sort of similarly to Jews and
Christians since God created us in His
image it would stand to reason he
wouldn't create others in different
images or there are all sorts of
sentient aliens out there and there is
no God
the last option scares me by the way and
the anxiety it causes drives me to do
more UFO research ok well hi Matt first
of all I appreciate that you admitted
that you have a lot of time on your
hands
ok and I really mean that sincerely
because I feel like we live in a culture
where everyone is constantly pretending
that they're busy and if they're so busy
they have so much to do they're so tired
they never sleep they never eat you know
everyone's constant they're so stressed
I mean while all of us actually have a
ton of free time which is which is why
we're online and watching Netflix and
stuff all the time
so the fact that you would just admit
that I think it's great now let me put
your mind at rest here but I don't think
there's any reason to conclude that the
existence of sentient aliens would
disprove God in fact I think it would
make the case for God even stronger
because think about it there are 100
billion galaxies in the universe the
known universe 100 billion galaxies
galaxies okay they're 100 billion of
them just try to wrap your head around
you can't there's something like a
hundred billion galaxies with a hundred
billion solar systems in each galaxy and
then so multiply that and then multiply
you know however many planets on average
are around any given star you start
doing the math you see that we are just
one infant essa mille speck of dust
orbiting a slightly bigger speck of dust
I mean ours our Sun is you know it's
it's a it's it's it's bigger than some
other Suns out there some other stars
but it is not even close to the biggest
star or the biggest class of stars there
are stars that you know you could fit
like a billion of our Suns into some of
the other stars that are out there so
we're just one speck of dust orbiting
another speck of dust in a little tiny
solar system in a in a relatively
unimpressive galaxy what are the chances
when you look at the entire scope of
things that all the rest of it is empty
nothing but emptiness and then just us I
think there's almost no chance of that
mathematically speaking does that
disprove God no because think about this
one of the most commonly cited and I
think best even Hitchens said that this
was a good argument for God is the the
fine-tuning argument the idea that the
universe is improbably calibrated to
make life possible well and it is right
but if the universe is is teeming with
life that would seem to underscore the
fact that Wow well the universe really
is finely tuned for life I mean it's so
big and and somehow all this life popped
up everywhere I think that that would
speak even more profoundly to the
existence of God if however the universe
is completely dead except for just one
little speck of dust then it becomes a
lot harder to say that this massive
gargantuan almost completely dead thing
is finely tuned for life in fact I think
I think at that point the argument loses
all of its for so it would be kind of
absurd really to say that a universe
that is totally dead except for this one
tiny barely perceptible corner of it to
say that that's finely tuned for life
I mean I think the phrase finely tuned
there would start to lose its meaning
now that that wouldn't disprove God
either but it would significantly
mitigate one of our best arguments for
God so I I wouldn't be afraid at all of
the prospect of sentient beings being
out there I think they are and doesn't I
don't think as it has any effect on
faith except possibly a positive effect
how does it work with their own
salvation history and everything I have
no idea I mean I just don't know it's
also possible other option here is that
there's a ton of life out there but but
not know no other intelligent life you
said sentient you know we talked about
what that means exactly but I think
there's probably a lot of intelligent
life out there too but you don't have to
worry about it and I wouldn't bother
studying it too much honestly although
if it interests you go for it but it's I
can tell you this there have never been
any aliens on earth and there never will
be
I hate to say I would love if they came
and be awesome but it never has happened
it never will happen we will never
encounter life out there in the in the
universe because the distances are just
too great it's simply you can't I I
don't think it's possible to traverse
these distances I think it's just
physically impossible look the closest
star to us I think is um like 4 light
years away well as I mentioned on the
show a couple days ago a light year is
like five trillion miles okay so this is
you're talking about something that's 20
or 25 trillion miles away and that's the
closest star to us which is just right
next door and it's quite possible
there's no life there but but even if
there was life right next door to us I
think we would never find it we would
never know about it because going across
20 trillion miles of interstellar space
we just even if you're going to the
speed of light it would take you four
years to do and and even we don't even
have the technology for two people to
survive in a spaceship for four years
you know with the radiation and all that
so anyway so III wouldn't worry too much
about it we're never gonna know it's
just something it's an interesting thing
to think about though and speculate
about but I don't think it affects our
religion one way or another
really honestly so I'll leave it there
thanks for thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show Rolling Stone magazine
celebrates the burning of Notre Adam as
an act of liberation meanwhile library
journal condemns libraries as tools of
white supremacy and anti white Democrats
only want to nominate a white guy we
will analyze how the West lost its mind
check it out at daily wire calm